when it comes to education what's more
important knowledge
or the teacher is there a better way to
teach our kids
is it time to innovate the old school
with new school tech
what if your teacher was ai
today on what if discussed
[Music]
welcome to what if disgust i'm richard
garner and i'm peter schmiechen
and richard did you have a favorite
teacher growing up
uh i did like aristotle
are you that old cave drawings and no i
mean
like most people uh you know i have a
few
probably a handful uh i wouldn't say
shape my life not necessarily those
stories of those like inspirational
teachers from the movies necessarily
um you know the the robin williams you
know
captain mike happy yeah that i i always
wished i did
i wouldn't say i had that but definitely
i can remember some teachers
that that had an impact on me and
probably if you ask them they might
also say that i had an impact on them
but not necessarily in a positive way
that's a story for another one right of
course what about you
well i did i had a few uh mr slater
obviously stands out mr montgomery
from my high school but for the most
part i got along with all of my teachers
i liked all my teachers
the ones i liked the best were the ones
you were able to talk to on a one-on-one
basis sort of like sitting
sitting around after class talking about
the world or talking about life
i mean learning was the one thing but uh
but for me like
a real connection came through um
chit chat conversation human
relationships yeah what do you think if
we visit a classroom in a hundred years
what are they going to say who's their
favorite teacher
teachbot 3000 teach bot 3000.
what an impact it had on me uh i don't
know i mean certainly that's the
the you know the the core of the
discussion that we're going to have
today and it's already been going
on education's already been on the sort
of table for innovation for a long time
and tech has already started you know
not started probably for
you know 10 plus years kids are using
you know
laptops at school the internet's more
part of education but when you start to
get to that next level
when you're talking not just about ai in
classrooms and some people that's as far
as they want to go
some people are talking about ai
literally replacing teachers
at some point which is of course always
going to be a controversial
topic i don't think i can imagine
that teachbot 3000 type thing unless
we're at a westworld level of ai
right which is super sci-fi and that's
maybe a concern
of another kind right i mean i don't
necessarily
see us being there right now but it's
like everything else
it's being fast-tracked as a discussion
topic but i don't know if it's
necessarily
there yet but right now ai and
education's a hot topic
yeah it certainly would have been handy
during the pandemic
for for learning i think a lot of a lot
of us found that the schools were caught
flat-footed and
you know not of for any fault of their
own but uh
you know nobody was expecting this but
had we had ai learning
we could have just you know had full day
full day school but as it stood
you know most schools that i know were
you know an hour a day at most
unless you were in the private school
system where they were all getting paid
to be there
and and paid big bucks then they were
teaching you all day long but
in the public school system i found it
was a little bit lacking
i don't know maybe ai is something that
could have helped help that out
and you don't have to pay ai
well or you might that's another
something that there
is a social discussion is should ai be
paid a wage but that's a story
for another what if someone who knows a
little bit more
about us than about ai and its potential
impact on education
is our next guest professor joanna
bryson studied behavioral science at the
university of chicago
and later completed an msc in artificial
intelligence
before an m phil in psychology at the
university of edinburgh
she got her phd from mit and her
post-doctoral fellowship
at harvard university she once worked
for lego as an
ai consultant researching child-oriented
programming techniques
in 2020 she became professor of ethics
and technology at
herte school of governance in berlin
professor bryson has
spoken at the world economic forum and
regularly appears in the media talking
about
human robot relationships and the ethics
of ai professor bryson thanks for
joining us
happy to be here so your education
and your professional background uh you
know there's
it seems like there's a pretty obvious
balance between the study of human
behavior
artificial intelligence and ethics i'm
guessing
that wasn't random that that was by
design
why for you was striking that balance
so important i would say that i wasn't
even that interested in only human
intelligence i was interested in
intelligence in general so i just wanted
to understand how things worked and
intelligence was one of the cool things
um and so
i was interested in animals not human
animals because
i felt like people had a lot of weird
theories about themselves
and if we didn't even understand sort of
how the hardware works how it works
before you get language and culture and
all that
then you don't know where you are so i
used artificial intelligence just
because i was good at it i was a good
programmer
and i realized it gave me sort of a
competitive advantage so i
i thought if i went uh with artificial
intelligence i might get into a good
graduate school and i was right
so that worked uh worked out for me but
the ethics thing was uh
was well i mean it was partly my
upbringing i was brought up my mother
actually had a master's degree in
christian education
um but so we went to a very liberal uh
christian church
and so i got a lot more uh sort of moral
education
than in america we're allowed to have in
the in the public schools
um and when i was a undergraduate i was
confronted by
understanding again this geeky
understanding of how
circuits worked so the first time uh
someone explained
it was i can i still remember it was
about how uh
it works how your eyes track so it's the
cutting of your vision
and and it was the circuit of neurons
and i could see exactly how it worked
and i thought but where is
that is a human behavior where is our
where is our consciousness in it where
is our
um where is our ethical obligation so i
you know from i was very uh
fascinated by that aspect as well and i
kept
up on it even though i didn't keep up on
my religion but i did keep up
on um just being aware of
social impacts so my first ai
ethics paper was actually because i
noticed people thought
that if your robot is shaped like a
person you owed it a moral obligation
and they were proud of that the robot
didn't even have to work but they were
proud it was like
they they said we've learned from
feminism we've learned from civil
rights that you know you have to be
generous about what a person is and like
you know if you learned if what you
learned from feminism is that a pile of
motors is as much like a white male as a
woman is like a white male then i think
feminism has some more work to do
and similar for uh for a civil rights
movement
you're currently a professor but as we
heard in your bio obviously you're a
very accomplished student as well you've
spent a lot of time in school
when assessing the pros and cons of ai
as a teacher what hat do you wear the
student hat or the professor hat
so when i took artificial intelligence
both at edinburgh where i first did my
master's degree
and at mit not so much when i took it as
when i tutored it for the undergraduates
um i noticed that lots of my classmates
were coming in
really excited at the beginning of the
class and
uh and they they really thought oh boy
oh boy ai this is the coolest part of
our degree right
and then they walked out of the
classroom that's not ai and i was like
blown away by what i was learning in
these same classes
and i think and i like what is the
difference and i thought the difference
was that i had those courses from
chicago for my liberal arts degree
on um on the biological basis of
behavior so i saw
the commonality between what we were
learning about ai
and and how human intelligence really
works and
the in most people because they had no
idea at least most computer scientists
had no idea
how the brain worked or or how you know
they didn't even understand basic
psychology
sometimes um they didn't see that there
was any relevance to their lives or to
understanding themselves
so that's why i've tried to write
courses where
students can both learn how to program
so they can get those intuitions about
what's hard and what's easy
but also i try to bring in the the
bioscience that
like here's how the brain is um and so
that they can see both those pieces
it's sort of an interesting segue to the
whole idea of you know dualism right we
get into this
binary type of thinking where it's
either or
and in your case obviously you're you're
a fan of of making
sure that people are sort of learning
these things in parallel in the same way
that people talk about this
issue right it becomes you know our
teachers
out and it's ai's only our teacher is
being replaced and of course there's
different ways of looking at this
perhaps as some ai coming in and
complementing teachers
helping them actually free up more time
to
teach how do you see that sort of
relationship working
i'm really interested in this in general
for the future of work but i often use
teaching as the example
so a lot of people think artificial
intelligence takes jobs
so first of all it's not the ai that
takes jobs
artificial intelligence is always an
artifact so somebody has built it
so it might be that a company decides to
replace part of its business process
with ai instead of humans but there are
people that are behind that decision so
it's not the technology itself doing it
first of all
but next let's say i as a programmer go
away and write something that makes
teachers twice as efficient
there's absolutely zero in that
statement that says
do we have twice as good a classes or
half as many teachers
that decision is a political decision
and so that's why i'm in a governance
school
oh i think there's an awful lot of
things going on right now where people
are um creating
um uh you know smoke and mirrors they're
trying to
evade regulation they don't see that
regulation is something that helps them
innovate that you know that that
massive regulation investment has come
into technology so that we could have
the companies we have
um yet anyway while they're trying to do
that they try to hide behind these weird
masks about what ai really is
but but those decisions it's not
inevitable from the technology it's a
human decision
about how you're going to augment
whether you're going to
augment the same number of people or
you're going to augment fewer people
once you build this intelligence what
you really do when you develop and
you know any kind of technology actually
but especially intelligent technology
is that you're making the humans more
valuable because they're all more
powerful
so it makes more sense to employ them
and you should actually be paying them
higher wages
okay professor bryson come with me now
into our what if time machine
and we're going to transport ourselves
into the future into the future
classroom and say just 30 years the year
2050
what does the classroom look like and
who or what is teaching
well i i think you're still going to
find uh if if you have classrooms i just
mentioned that you're going to have a
whole
like an increasing number of students
sort of staying home and self-isolating
but but if you where you have classrooms
i think you will definitely have
teachers i hope that you actually have
multiple teachers
per classroom and then i think i'll i
hope that you can have maybe age
diversity a lot all kinds of diversity
in the students so that they could be
moving between the spaces as
is appropriate to to the level of
education they need
so i'd like to see technology making it
easier to do some of the administrative
perspectives of like not only
customizing you know within a particular
topic
but really within the entire flow um
so i think and of course it again it
depends a lot on the decisions we're
making right now as we
as we experience the opportunities and
the challenges of things like pandemics
and other political challenges that are
happening right now so if we get to a
point
where uh where we have a more
egalitarian system
then we're going to see one set of
things across a range of classrooms
but if we go to in another direction
where some students are going to have
like the most amazing
you know customized little environments
and they're going to be building their
own robots and the other kids are going
to have you know paper
paper and pencil and a piled mud or
something you know that that is one of
the things i worry about a lot
so um but i guess i what i said at the
beginning was my more
my more optimistic uh uh vision
my vision is that you have
spaces that people can move through and
that the technology can allow
you to um to move through them and to
find the right education for the right
thing but to still get to know a cohort
of people
and to still have more human interaction
i i hope that in 30 years we will have
a higher uh teacher to student ratio so
more teachers per student i don't know
what i just said
that the uh so and and
because the teachers are going to be
able to do so much more with the
technology that's going to be so much
more clearly adding the value
another thing i'd like to see honestly
is that the students are younger
i i would like to see that we allow more
diversity of life and career paths so
maybe if it's really a school
it's going to end a little earlier and
then the students can
can actually i mean you know look at
look at the uh amazing things teenagers
are capable of
so that there's a more of a flow i guess
i
the students are younger if it's just a
classroom but that there's there's more
opportunities for lifetime experience of
going out
working maybe when you're younger than
coming back to school we already see
this more in europe than you do
in america of not you don't have to like
get all the teaching over and then get
all the working over or whatever there's
more of a
flow but i would hope in fact a lot of
people say it's going to be a necessity
that we'll have more opportunities so
that um over
some age i don't know i'm not i'm not
keeping up on this but over the age of
maybe 13 or 14
um that you would already start getting
into this flow of maybe having a little
career having a side
uh thing that you're doing running a
small business or something or working
somewhere um and then coming back and
and and and
making your education more of a part of
the flow of your entire
uh life and career well a lot to think
about
and a lot to process there no pun
intended
but uh we really appreciate you joining
us and taking the time
uh professor bryce and where can people
find your work and what do you kind of
have upcoming
that people might be interested in in
following
well if you want to follow me follow me
on twitter j2bryson um and that tends to
link to everything else
actually we're just about to launch a
new beta version of my webpage
and i'm trying to write a book that's my
exciting summer project so
yeah everything everything happens but
you can google me easily
well we'll we'll keep an eye out for
that and uh get ai to write your book
yes yeah now that would take all the fun
out now there's a business idea
for you and i yes um but a story for
another whatever yes
uh thanks doc uh thanks professor bryce
for joining us to take in the time
and and really helping the what if
audience really understand what's a
pretty complex issue
it is yeah thank you well quite the
education
on ai and education with professor
bryson but as she talked about
learning doesn't necessarily have to be
something that is just part of your
early life that actually
lifelong learning is now becoming the
bigger trend and that we should all be
learning going forward
uh forever really well and
and uh you seem like a guy who never
wants to stop learning
well i mean we're lucky enough that we
learn every time we're on the show like
this but we don't always have access
to the top thought leaders except
maybe we do ah well you could become
more informed creative
and inspired all with the great courses
plus richard
we're really big on the streaming
service are we well i mean it's easy to
talk about because it's very similar to
what if discussed right you get access
to top thought leaders you get to
essentially learn on your own time and
be able to sort of
pick subjects that you want to sort of
immerse yourself in and obviously
we're big proponents of curiosity
continuing to learn and fascination and
obviously
when you have sort of a an archive like
great courses plus have you can pretty
much pick and choose
yeah so one of the ones that i'm
watching right now is called the
fundamentals of photography
i highly recommend it uh do you take
pictures richard i do
yeah not good well everyone takes
pictures not everybody takes good
pictures most people are just shooting
in auto mode yes um i'm speaking
specifically more of dslrs but
also on your camera phone as well or
your phone camera
um so you can take good pictures on auto
but if you want to take really good
pictures
you got to get out of the auto mode go
into manual and start flicking
flicking around with stuff and then you
can actually create depths of field with
your aperture and sort of stuff like
that
this is what i'm learning on great
courses plus um
the course that i'm uh watching is being
taught by
uh joel sartori he's an acclaimed
photographer for national geographic
magazine wow he makes it so easy for me
just to remember
what to do with my camera settings but
more importantly it's it's remembering
why i'm doing that you know the great
courses plus has
thousands of lectures on almost any
topic imaginable from the history of
egypt to the study of dna and
new courses are being added all the time
there's something for everyone plus
every course like joel sartori is
presented by
subject matter experts from top
universities and institutions
it's in-depth reliable fact-based
information and
you can watch or listen from your phone
or your tv with the great courses plus
app
at any time from anywhere in the world
make the most of your time keep learning
with the great courses plus
right now they're offering fans of our
show an amazing deal
an entire month of access for free
this limited time offer won't last so
sign up today to get started go to
thegracecoursesplus.com
what if don't wait the
greatcoursesplus.com
what if what is it richard the great
courses thegreatcoursesplus.com
what if bingo cm learning you got it but
i mean
it is an interesting segue it's easier
to talk about stuff like great courses
plus
on a show like this because that's kind
of what the model is right we
you know we're not subject matter
experts although some of you might think
so
no no but you would be you would be
wrong we are
really we're the proxy for the listener
and and the viewer at home
who have a level of fascination
curiosity but we want to be able to have
access to the top people in the world
well we we got
access today to one of the top people in
the world in this field
professor joanna bryson is like again
like we said in her bio off the top
like she's educated she's like i mean
you're naming ivy league schools and mit
and all the stuff but she's also the one
who's
who's going to the world economic forum
in davos when people want to have a
panel discussion
about the future of ai so we're lucky
enough to have her today
this is the place to come for uh well i
mean and great courses buzz
but uh in that same vein what did you
learn today
i learned right off the top she was
talking about how we learn better
from ai when it's shaped like a human
being yeah which i had never thought of
but of course you just
you recognize that shape as being
something that you can
relate to and they're trying to tell you
something of course you're going to
listen it's
much better than you know one of these
skulls beside you trying to
trying to tell me i'm not going to
listen to that saber-tooth tiger yes or
the old like the models in the movies
like short circuit or whatever like
doctor johnny five yeah
shot in toronto you know what the with
the old robot looked like and you know
you know peter sit down put down that
whatever like that type of stuff
that's kind of how we used to think we
are talking about but not not anytime
soon about that sort of that more ai
that
looks for lack of a better word like a
human we're not there yet
no but what we did understand i think
from her so
we could be though soon alicia vickender
and uh yes one
i'm a big fan of hers and in the role
yes but in this particular case
like i think it's again it's one of
those things where we get into binary
conversations or dualistic conversations
it's either or
are we are humans or no humans no i
think what she's talking about is that
there's plenty of things
that we already know logistically
scheduling
admin a lot of things that aren't really
part of teaching
weigh down most of the bandwidth of
teachers so
they constantly are arguing for more
prep time but we could eliminate
all the all the hassle stuff and give
them the prep time and that to me is
that's the best solution and i don't
think we have to worry about you know
sort of again teachbot 3000
for decades to come i just don't think
the technology is there and i i think
the world would be in a a much bitter
or a much different place by then but
for now i would be curious if you ask
most teachers if you could eliminate all
that
prep time stuff grading papers uh admin
and all those things and you could just
focus on what you love the passion you
have to connect
with the kids be able to have more
one-on-one time wouldn't wouldn't most
teachers go for that don't you think it
could be a huge weight lifted off their
shoulders i think that's why most
teachers got into the most teachers some
of them got into it for the for the
summers off
but most teachers probably got into this
business because they have a passion
to teach or passion to tell stories to
children help them learn
um so yeah that would be that would be
incredible well i'm a big fan
of not the either or but
and or with and in this particular case
i think the ai
part of it can complement education a
model i think we'd all agree is
needed innovation for a long time is
currently under innovation
and i don't think we have to jump to
this sort of the worst case scenario at
this point i think there's a lot of time
to worry about that later
yeah if you enjoyed this conversation
we carry it on later click on the link
in the description below and get our
extended audio version
professor yuta trevoranus joins us she's
the founder of the inclusive design
research center
and the inclusive design institute and
she may have some contrary opinions
to our first guest think that's possible
yeah i think so like i mean i know her
work she's somebody that's
uh not necessarily raining on the parade
but she wants to
highlight a lot of the red flags that we
already know about current ai and
everything else and make sure that at
least we're considering these things
before we go down the path
and it's too late yeah keep us keeping
us honest and we're keeping you honest
we'll see you next time on what if
discussed
[Music]
you